bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8
week-end votre magazine sorties et
loisirs
au sommaire jusqu'à dimanche saint
quentin en yvelines est le théâtre d'un
festival pour d'une même problématique
l'environnement ce week-end la commune
de rambouillet propose de nombreux
rendez vous pour son festival dédié
cette année à l'arménie nous
découvrirons le travail de jean-pierre
evrard un photographe irina notamment
passionnés notamment par l'egypte une
capture tout particulièrement regard des
émotions ce jeudi a débuté le festival
saint quentin quatre jours de
projections autour d'un même thème
l'environnement il hier soir avait lieu
la cérémonie d'ouverture à l'ugc ciné
cité de saint quentin en yvelines
retour sur la soirée avec sephora namani
et camille lambert
nous avons décidé de commencer notre
tour du monde à abou dhabi
ce qui nous permet d'imposer de passer
l'un très tôt dans la saison à voir les
mousses ans mais aussi abou dhabi
cerveau de manière logique à cause de sa
diversification dans les énergies
renouvelables
cela rime pulse 2 laventure de deux
suisses pour réaliser un tour du monde à
bord d'un avion nous nos places propulsé
par l'énergie solaire et premier
documentaire projeté lors du festival
saint quentin la coke 21 c'est un grand
un grand rendez vous et je suis persuadé
que la voiture se la riposte fait partie
des professions boli qui montrent qu'on
peut changer de vie et que c'est pas la
catastrophe qui s'annonce vers nous
c'est une aventure particulière juste on
pour éviter cette catastrophe organisé
pendant le mois du film documentaire au
festival et son thème de l'environnement
et du climat s'inscrit aussi dans
l'optique de la grande conférence
internationale sur le climat qui se
tiendra à paris à partir du 30 novembre
prochain
je trouvais que ce festival est le
cliché mais comme un devoir projet de
belle intégration sur la réalité du
monde d'aujourd'hui qu'on découvre le
personnage tient des rêves plein la tête
mais qui font rêver les gens qui aura ce
soir ses vocalises ont vraiment des de
penser à autre chose est de voir des
films qui peuvent changer des choses et
l'important c'est de fédérer autour d'un
événement culturel au sens large
que ce soit des salles de ciné de cinéma
de spectacles d'autres lieux comme les
universités ou autres pour pouvoir créer
un événement qui est un peu différent de
ce que je vis dans un cinéma classique
et de pouvoir faire participer un public
dans différents lieux du territoire
pour cette première soirée de projection
saint quentin a rassemblé 4 170
personnes
le festival continue jusqu'au dimanche
15 novembre dans neuf lieux de 51000
l'île saint quentin c'est donc jusqu'au
dimanche 15 novembre ce week-end de
nombreux autres rendez vous sont
proposés toujours des projections
documentaires bien sûr des rencontres
mais aussi des ateliers et notamment ce
samedi au ciné cette d'elancourt vous
pourrez ainsi découvrir les bases de
prises de vues réelles et pourquoi pas
réaliser votre premier plan séquence
écoutait cécile giraud babouche la
coordinatrice de l'association contre
champ
à nîmes cet atelier et partira en fait
d'eux des origines du cinéma avec la
lumière lumière voilà qui réalisait ce
qu'on appelle des vues donc des plans
à ces cours de scènes de la vie
quotidienne
donc on remontera au début du siècle et
on leur fera découvert qu' on peut faire
du cinéma toujours
en plan séquence mais avec de nouveaux
outils donc les téléphones portables par
exemple la clôture du festival se fera
dimanche au ciné cette d'elancourt le
documentaire choisi vous plongera dans
l' aventure de l'expédition tara avant
de regarder un extrait écouter luc beau
quand le directeur du ciné set mais
c'est passionnant j'ai vu ce film à la
télévision je crois je me souviens plus
exactement mais il me semble que je les
ai vus à la télévision il ya quelques
années et je j'ai trouvé que l' aventure
de ses huit ou neuf je sais plus
exactement scientifique qui se laisse
comme ça qu'on voulait être complètement
prendre volontairement avec un bateau
qui résistent aussi qui a été conçu pour
ça dans la banquise pour faire des
expériences scientifiques
la vie en vase clos donc le documentaire
est très bien fait parce qu'on voit à la
fois
de quelle façon les choses se passent
entre eux donc c'est une aventure
humaine
nous nous connaissions à peine avant
d'embarquer sur tara et pourtant nous
allions passer huit mois ensemble
prisonniers du grand désert arctique au
coeur de l'hiver polaire
en septembre 2006 le voilier tara est
seul au milieu de l'océan arctique
emprisonné dans les glaces de la
banquise nous sommes huit hommes à son
bord et nous commençons une incroyable
expédition une dérive de 2000 km
prisonnier des glaces
si vous n'avez pas l'occasion de vous
rendre dans les salles obscures les
documentaires sont aussi à découvrir sur
notre antenne durant tout le week-end et
pour retrouver toute la programmation du
festival
l'adresse du site internet s'affiche en
bas de votre écran
on passe tout de suite là notre premier
rallye t on prend une toute autre
direction cette fois avec le festival de
rambouillet si l'événement a débuté en
octobre dernier ce week-end de nombreux
rendez vous sont à découvrir et pour en
parler nous a rejoint en plateau
christophe naba bonjour je vous êtes
directeur de la communication de la
commune de rambouillet alors cette année
c'est le quatrième festival culturel de
la commune et vous avez choisi pour
thème l'arménie pourquoi alors l'arménie
d'abord c'est le 100e anniversaire du
génocide
donc nous avons pensé qu'il fallait
marquer le coup sur cet événement
tragique mais c'est également parce que
nous avons la tradition à rambouillet
d'ouvrir la ville sur l'extérieur il ya
quelques années nous avions également
fait un festival sur le liban à chaque
fois ce sont des pays qui sont des pays
qui appartiennent à la francophonie
mais c'est également des pays qui ont
souffert qui ont traversé des périodes
de leur histoire dramatique et qui ont
une culture extrêmement vivante et qui
les aide à survivre donc les thèmes des
tables rondes qui vont avoir lieu demain
parle de ça parle de la culture et de sa
son pouvoir de résilience mais également
on aura des grands historiens qui vont
nous parler des questions géopolitiques
de cette zone qui sont en bordure de la
syrie de l'irak et des des zones
extrêmement tendue en ce moment
et je pense que ça va être très
intéressant pour tout le monde vous
disais cdpq histoire pas facile c'est le
moyen de faire découvrir aux gens cette
histoire parfois peu connus l'arménien
on entend finalement peu à part le
génocide tout à fait c'est un pays qui
est largement ignoré très très enclavée
un peu étouffé par ses énormes voisins
et mais qui a une culture très très
riche et très particulière et surtout
extrêmement ancienne puisque on dit que
c'est le berceau de du christianisme et
que trois siècles après jésus-christ
l'église arménienne était déjà
extrêmement vivante
aucun retrait je vous l'avais dit et
notamment vous proposer des expositions
photos des concerts
ces artistes vous les avez découvert
comment alors on les a découvert au fur
et à mesure de la construction et de
l'élaboration de ce festival qui je dois
le dire a été conçu par marie carré
semelle une élue du conseil municipal de
rambouillet qui avait à coeur de faire
connaître aux rambolitains cette culture
très riche donc elle est allée petit à
petit à la rencontre des des arméniens
que l'on connaît on connaît tous
robert guédiguian ce grand réalisateur
mais on connaît aussi assez bien
antoine agoudjian qui est un grand
photographe et petit à petit en
rencontrant ces arméniens de france on a
découvert d'autres arméniens d'autres
grands artistes que l'on a invité à
rambouillet vous disais tout à l'heure
vous savez parler de robert guédiguian
et mardi prochain le 17 novembre sans
notamment une histoire de fou avec simon
abkarian ariane ascaride et grégoire
leprince ringuet
le long métrage parle notamment du
génocide des arméniens sa reconnaissance
voire carrément ça nous reconnaissait
dans les années 80 et la projection se
fera en présence du réalisateur et de
l'acteur principal c'est le moyen aussi
de d'être au plus près des gens tout à
fait c'est un moyen de faire en sorte
que l'ensemble de la population de
de notre ville de rambouillet puisse
être contacter d'autres cultures donc il
ya des programmes qui sont adaptées au
plus jeune âge on a on a créé des
ateliers pour les tout petits sur des
miniatures puisque c'est une des
caractéristiques de la culture
arménienne
on a ouvert aussi à des artistes style
manoukian un qui va se produire à la
maison des jeunes et de la culture
et puis effectivement le cinéma de
robert guédiguian il va être mis à
l'honneur
et surtout on a l'honneur de et le
plaisir d'accueillir robert guédiguian
lui même avec son acteur fétiche que
tout le monde connaît simon abkarian et
qui je pense va faire venir beaucoup de
monde découvrir l'histoire de l'arménie
puisque effectivement cette histoire en
fout parle de l'histoire de l'arménie et
des de cette difficulté que les
arméniens ont eu de faire reconnaître le
génocide
justement ce film je vous propose de
regarder la bande annonce
nous sommes deux purs révolutionnaire
solitaire indépendant orgueilleux et
fier aucune force au monde ne pourra
salir notre lutte ni épuiser notre
volonté
vous perçu venger comme tehlirian peut
au moins ils ont tué une cinquantaine
des cent criminels de la liste qu'ils
avaient et ami depuis plus rien aux
générations à renoncer
vous êtes vos propres fossoyeurs soyons
les héritiers de télé rial et finissons
son oeuvre de justice justice pour le
peuple arménien est aujourd'hui que
justin maignien je n'ai jamais trahi
personne plutôt respecte pour ça et pour
le reste tu me méprise
on a toutes les raisons de penser qu'ils
sachent terroristes armés
parra m'agace et attentats des partis
ont rejoint désormais à beyrouth baigner
je voulais vous demander pardon je me
fous du peuple arménien c'est peut-être
mon fils que vous a fait sa pub le saut
au-dessus de 15%
je dois arrêter d'y penser les voisins
pensent la plupart des armées nation
contre la violence la plupart sous votre
fils qu'est ce qu'il veut ajouté sue
veut parler à rome c'est ça pour moi
c'est de la folie
on repasse bouton et jamais s'il veut
voir son bourreau en saas
se compare à son bord selon l'office
fédéral
christophe manas on a vu la
bande-annonce tous les rendez vous pour
le public ça se passe comment alors
c'est très simple pour demain les tables
rondes sont ouvertes à tous et gratuit
donc venez à 15 heures au relais du
château c'est tout près du château de
rambouillet et là vous verrez de grands
spécialistes de l'histoire arménienne et
en présence du président du sénat gérard
larcher mais également animée par brice
couturier journalistes connus de france
culture
et puis vous pourrez en profiter pour
aller voir à 200 mètres de là les très
belles expositions photos notamment de
d'antona good gyan qui vraiment a fait
un très beau travail sur son pays nous
parler de ce festival on vous l'a dit ça
commence dès demain avec deux
expositions
ce week-end aura lieu à versailles un
salon des métiers d'art c'est le premier
salon organisé par la chambre des
métiers de l'artisanat
il rassemblera des verriers des
tailleurs de pierre ou encore des
restaurateurs d'objets anciens
écoutez écoutez et blink azotés de la
chambre des métiers
notre objectif est de mettre en valeur
ces artisans qui sont des passeurs de
voyage de rêve de création sur des
métiers
lié à notre passé également à notre
devenir
ils sont 53 sur le salon et vous avez
sur le territoire des îles inuits 160
entreprises artisanales qualifié de
métiers d'art avant d'accueillir nos
deux prochains invités qui eux nous
parlerons photographier nous prenons la
direction du pavé du canal cette semaine
laurent garat s'intéresse à qui vivra
qu'il mourra un ouvrage qui vous plonge
dans un monde où il n'y a pas assez de
ressources pour vivre qui vivra kimura
c'est la question centrale de cet
ouvrage de savoir qui arrivera à
survivre dans des moments soit de
pandémie de guerre de famine et la
question donc de qui sera écarté dans un
groupe
normalement tout le monde doit
surveiller enfin la question centrale
donc et philosophique c'est finalement
qui écarté et qui conservait alors il
est aussi question d'éthique morale et
d'éthique médicale dans ce livre
concernant par exemple les greffons a
qui ont des dix finalement certains
greffon sur des cadavres
aussi concernant tous les vaccins à qui
on dédie les vaccins alors se pose la
réflexion de la question économique ou
de la question humanitaire dont toute la
réflexion du livre va se porter sur
comment réagir vis-à-vis de ces crises
et quelles décisions doit-on prendre
vis-à-vis de tout ça ce que moi j'ai
trouvé très troublant et finalement très
intéressant et très profond dans ce
livre c'est que l'auteur met en
perspective des événements historiques
comme la shoah comme la guerre comme la
famine en afrique
et elle met en perspective vis-à-vis de
fiction contemporaine
donc elle met par exemple spider man qui
a le choix entre sauver une vingtaine de
gamins qui sont bloqués dans un
téléphérique ou sauver mary jane
voilà donc cette façon de
conte maintenant que ce soit les romans
jeunesse où toutes les fictions
contemporaines d'avoir cette ce choix de
sélection entre qui doit rester et qui
doit doit mourir
l'auteur s'articule tout autour d'eux
donc de nos fictions qui sont là de tous
les jours que l'on peut voir soit dans
le roman soit dans nos films et ces
questions-là reste aussi central sur ces
fictions tout au long du livre l'auteur
nous montre le lien qui peuvent donc
exister entre les fictions
contemporaines et tous les événements
tragiques qui ont pu avoir lieu durant
toute l'histoire
et finalement ce n'est pas forcément le
trafic qui prend le dessus et on peut
avoir une vraie réflexion concernant ces
décisions pour continuer cette suite
week-end votre magazine sorties et
loisirs nous allons maintenant parler du
8e art et plus particulièrement de la
photographie claude chose bonjour vous
êtes président de l'union régionale
photographique vous venez régulièrement
ici pour nous parler de concours photo
mais cette fois vous avez tenu à nous
présenter un photographe professionnel
qui étaient là qui est là avec nous il
s'agit de jean pierre brard bonjour à
tous les deux alors que l'autre chose
pourquoi déjà avoir choisi de nous
présenter le travail de jean-pierre
evrard mes jambes je connais jean pierre
depuis plusieurs années je toujours été
surpris et très agréablement surpris par
son travail ces quelques quelqu'un aussi
qui m'a aidé en tant que photographe à
juger mes photos et jean-pierre au sein
de la fédération photographique a
souvent été le juge de décompte de la
coupe de france noir et blanc est entre
autres la dernière fois et
3 villennes-sur-seine et en 2010 je suis
quoi c'était aussi un issy les
moulineaux donc jean-pierre à une
carrière de photographe très longue il a
travaillé chez un important quand on
s'appelle énorme une importante
entreprise de la photo puisqu'il a été
longtemps chez kodak
mais je pense que le mieux c'est de lui
laisser la parole pour qu'il puisse nous
expliquer lui-même simuler ce qu'il a
fait jean-pierre evrard est ce que vous
pourriez nous faire un petit résumé de
votre parcours vous êtes très rapide je
suis rentré dans photographier par la
voie de l'apprentissage et après mon
service militaire
simplement je vais l'attention de me
perfectionner je suis je suis rentré
chez kodak jeu seule chose que je
n'avais pas prévu c'est que cinq ans
après j'avais cinq enfants
ce qui fait que j'ai trouvé beaucoup
plus prudent de rester dans une grande
société qui m'apporte énormément sur le
plan technique parce que veulent bien
sûr bénéficier de la pelote des
ingénieurs kodak sais c'est une très
très grande richesse et je suis resté
donc plusieurs années en charge
notamment de l'information marketing
développeurs professionnels
après je suis j'ai quitté kodak
lorsque mes enfants étaient élevés et je
suis rentré dans une agence qui était à
l'époque à ses côtés qu'ils appelaient
l'agent ce métis qui malheureusement a
fermé comme beaucoup de d'âge ans par la
suite par l'évolution des techniques et
je me suis consacré donc ces dix
dernières années surtout à la vente dans
les galeries puisque j'ai deux galeries
qui me représente à paris et puisque mon
plaisir c'est de travailler beaucoup
plus même beaucoup avec des musées ou
avec des collectionneurs vous exposez
beaucoup on a vu plusieurs de vos photos
à l'écran qu'est ce qui vous attire pour
prendre une photo à un regard un
mouvement une situation oui vous avez
prononcé un maul qui est très important
pour moi c'est le regard là cela voudra
fils titus est un moyen de communiquer
et notamment comme je suis très
spécialisée sur l'afrique puisque j'ai
passé une grande partie de ma carrière
même lorsque j'étais chez kodak j'ai
découvert l'afrique est donc
c'est vraiment mon dieu préféré et y'a
rien qui me met plus en colère lorsque
je vois des des amateurs qui est son
avec dans ces pays là avec des appareils
de crohn grande focale qui se cache
derrière honda pour photographier des
gens qui veulent pas les photographier
alors que pour moi au contraire je suis
je travaille très très près des gens à
un mètre et je veux que les gens me
regardent je veux qu'ils participent à
voir photo et ça c'est pour ça c'est
très important pour moi
le regard ça c'est alors moi ce qui m'a
mathier d'une part le regard disant je
suis les conseils de 2 comment s'appelle
de jean-pierre c'est clair si vous
voulez que moi aussi dans la
photographie je m'appuie sur le regard
de la communication avec les gens je
quand je demande toujours des
autorisations aux gens de les
photographier mais moi ce qui me que
j'aime beaucoup dans le travail de jean
pierre c'est aussi son travail sur la
lumière et les ombres
donc je sais pas ce que tu pourrais nous
en dire parce que je crois que c'est
quelque chose de très important chez toi
oui c'est très important
en été je reste un petit peu ce sur
l'afrique parce que j'ai photographié
dans beaucoup de pays mais l'afrique
c'est quand même le pays qui m'intéresse
le plus il y a il a deux types de
lumière il ya de la lumière de l'afrique
de l'ouest et à la lumière de l'afrique
du nord
c'est un petit peu comme dans un studio
dans un studio il y a des y'a des
parapluies devront explorer avec des
grands parapluies peut donner une
lumière très douce
ça c'est l'afrique de l'ouest et puis un
despote et cela avec lumières traité
très très dirigé avec des zombies très
fort ça c'est l'afrique du nord et ça
demande un travail particulier
finalement faut avoir un certain deuil
pour prendre son temps peut-être oui il
faut abattre l'ex va voir et puis
l'homme notamment sur sur le maroc
je recherche à composer mes photos en
temps quand énormément énormément des
ombres et des lumières c'est pour moi
c'est un petit peu une disons le décor
de mes photos l'ombre la lumière et
surtout beaucoup de travail sur le noir
et blanc c'est une volonté particulière
vas y que qu'en noir et blanc je
travaille sur l'argentique au c'est
peut-être une solution de facilité mais
je suis un photographie argentique
depuis l'âge de 18 ans c'est un métier
que je connais bien c'est un métier qui
disparaît un petit peu tout doucement
tout doucement pour faire place aux
nouvelles technologies alors je dis
attention cette place que je tiens un
petit pas la défendre jusqu'au bout
parce que c'est ce sont des techniques
qu'ils vont disparaître peut-être
peut-être pas mais ont failli et un
savoir faire qui est important que je
possède et donc autant au temps de
l'utiliser au maximum
l'argentique ça doit demander une
certaine réflexion quand même ce n'est
pas comme actuellement les numériques on
peut prendre beaucoup de photos est
supprimée derrière c'est évident mais il
ya quand même dire que même dans trop de
gras fille a toujours la notion de choix
et que ce soit fait en
rafale ou pas du tout il ya arrivé un
moment où on se trouve
pour moi c'est face à ma chambre à ma
planche contact où j'ai toutes les
photos que j'avais faite sur un film et
là on passe beaucoup beaucoup de temps à
éliminer à choisir des photos était rare
mais ça fait un petit peu au même
oui de le faire le soir entendre à
l'hôtel puis de la réflexion ça fait
avant taux plutôt qu'après on le fait un
petit peu après et dans les photos qu'on
a vu tout à l'heure à l'écran il y en a
deux moi qui m'ont particulièrement
marqué finalement claude chaumont
n'affiche pas le même choix voilà la
première est ce que vous pouvez
jean-pierre evrard m'expliquer
l'histoire de cette photo oui c'est une
liste c'est êtes une rencontre
extrêmement extrêmement rapide j'ai dit
ça s'est passé à bangui en centrafrique
jeu photographier dans à l'intérieur
d'une école de filles et j'étais en
cours de récréation et les autres jouets
et arrive à un moment où la maîtresse
tape dans les mains et tout le monde se
met en ligne l'après dans ces pays là
sont très disciplinés sont même encore
l'uniforme serra et il ya tous les
élèves qui étaient groupés et terra prêt
à rentrer dans la classe et il est vrai
qu'une une dizaine ou une vingtaine et
il y avait cette petite fille tout de
suite qui m'attirait est elle aussi m'a
regardé et il vient petits moments de
complicité de quelques secondes que j'ai
jamais oublier j'ai fait cette photo et
j'étais ravi malheureusement
malheureusement ce qui se passe est très
souvent en afrique de m'a pris à une
révolution à bangui je sais que cette
école qui était une école privée tenue
par des religieuses a été entièrement
détruite
j'aurais bien aimé envoyé ma photo à
cette petite fille et pays qui
m'attendra 25 ans mère de famille à ma
place un très beau regard regarde moi je
suis ciblé
jean pierre m'a offert un tirage de
cette photo je dois dire qu'elle est
dans mon bureau et que je la regarde et
tous les tous mes amis qui la voient
sont absolument fasciné par cette
photographie donc
c'est clair mais jean-pierre aussi dans
son appareil photographique un rôle si
vous voulez et tient ce rôle qui est de
aussi de perpétuer vous savez des
métiers qui disparaissent peut-être que
tu peux nous en dire quelques mots jean
pierre c'est un petit peu le rôle d'un
photographe c'est de garder des traces
de moments qui ont existé qui n'existent
plus parce que même si ça s'est passé de
quelques secondes avant ça n'existe plus
donc ce sont des traces et il y a des
des métiers qui existent encore pas très
loin par exemple au maroc c'est quand
même tout près on voit encore des gens
qui travaillent qui file la laine qui
quittera gala chat rude et je n'oublie
pas que lorsque moi j'étais enfant tout
de suite après la guerre est bien tous
ces métiers existent en france il
n'existe plus de même les outils tous
les enfants de mon âge
à après la guerre il ya toujours un
moment qui demandait à l'enfant tiens à
ce que tu peux moudre le café dont elle
avait le moulin à café en tournée
maintenant ce moule à café on ne le voit
plus on le voit plus que chez les
antiquaires et bien c'est un petit peu
pareil tout cédé outils et bien j'aime
bien les les photographier la tradition
vous porte quand même dans les photos
oui oui que sir énormément c'est assure
quelque chose le travail de jean-pierre
evrard c'est inspirant pour un
photographe amateur ou professionnel
mais plus jeunes peut-être
disons que tous les gens de de notre
union régionale et même au sein de la
fédération photographique de france
apprécie le travail de jean-pierre
evrard lorsqu'il fait il des juges dans
des concours il est extrêmement
dont il donne beaucoup de conseils aux
gens il explique pourquoi il juge une
photo et ça je trouve que jean pierre
sur ce côté de ce test est là beaucoup
de mérite parce que il dit aux gens
pourquoi c'est comme ça et moi je peux
vous assurer que je rencontre souvent
jean-pierre avec mon propre travail pour
lui demander son avis parce que
contrairement à jean pierre je
travaillais en argent en numérique mais
jean-pierre mas a pris aussi à ma fait
des remarques sur parfois on pousse les
courses les curseurs un petit peu trop
et qu' on puisse donner à des la photo
numérique aujourd'hui le côté je vais
dire le reflet de ce que tu es la poudre
argentique ou vous avez de la douceur
dans l'est dans les dents les couleurs
ou dans l'aude et dans l'est dans le
noir et blanc qui permet si vous voulez
de de porter un rêve aux gens de faire
rêver les gens et de les faire de les
faire voyager
voilà merci à vous tous d'être venus je
vous espère peut-être que jean-pierre
evrard votre travail aura donné des
envies voire peut-être aller voir des
expositions je crois que vous avez vu
l'exposition halle aux veaux il ya deux
expositions dont je voulais vous parler
d'une part c'est le dans le cadre du
festival sur le documentaire 50
donc il ya des photos sur la les
paysages la nature qui sont exposées au
centre skywest si les deux au
rez-de-chaussée au pied des escaliers
qui mènent au cinéma et deuxièmement sur
la nature et vous avez de très belles
photos aériennes ou des des photos
d'ours blancs et de dun de noyon que
j'invite les gens parce que c'est une
espèce endémique
c'est l'oiseau avec sa banquette en
oiseaux tout à fait particulière qui vit
je crois que en ouganda est un peu plus
lointain villennes sur seine mais il ya
un invité d'honneur qui s'appelle michel
de d'oultremont et l'exposition et
d'expositions dur du 17 au 29 novembre
j'invite aussi donc c'est dans au photo
club de villennes sur seine qui peut
être un jour sera notre invité et
j'invite les gens à aller voir cette
exposition parce que c'est un travail
ce club fait un travail assez
remarquable sur la photo et sur la
photographie donc là et puis dernier
point je rappellerai notre concours cv
votre regard sur notre votre ville nous
attendons vos photos jusqu'à lundi 16
c'est très facile
vous prenez vous en voyez ça sur le
l'adresse mail rédaction @ nous serons
d'accueillir le vainqueur la la fois
dedans dans huit jours puisque nous
allons cela ce projet là merci à tous
les deux dates venu le 7-8 week-end
c'est terminé je vous remercie de nous
avoir suivis la semaine prochaine c'est
nucléaire et demi d'euros qui vous
proposera sorties et loisirs
d'ici là je vous souhaite un excellent
week end